ladies and gentlemen welcome to screen
junkies movie fights powered by the
popcorn talk network now your host andy
signor
hello screen junkies i am not andy
signora oh he is uh away this
week out through summer monday's
starting already uh i am dan merrell i'm
the producer of screen junkies as well
as the editor of honest trailers and
welcome to screen junkies movie fights
the show where real nerds get in real
fights over fake movies for real
indeed we've gone through this week's
news we have eight rounds of awesome
questions for you including is there
hope for the new fantastic four can m
night shyamalan make a comeback what's
the best quentin tarantino movie so much
cool stuff to talk about and if you
stick around for our final fight this
week you'll get a little hint at next
week's honest trailer
uh so before we start just a couple of
things we want to thank the popcorn talk
network for having us here thanks marie
munoz kevin undergaro as well as the
schmoe's no crew christian uh harloff
and mark ellis awesome guys mark ellis
is the cute one
uh
you can find lots of great movie content
on the popcorn talk youtube channel and
you can find this podcast on itunes you
can download it there subscribe rate and
check out lots of other great shows so
oh one more thing if you are watching
this on youtube we have a nifty little
feature called pick your fight at the
bottom right corner of your screen there
will be a little bug you can click that
and you can build your own little mega
movie fight so without further ado let's
get to this week's gladiators first of
all you know him you love him he's the
host of the screen junkies show mr hal
rednick thanks for having me dan uh i've
been getting ready for this all week
been eating a lot of chipotle in
preparation oh boy i'm glad i'm sitting
next to you hal uh next stop he's an
actor he's a comedian he's a returning
movie fights champion mike carlson hello
there thank you for having me back i'm
excited to participate it is our
pleasure and last but certainly not
least he's best friends with the rock
he's one of my favorite people in the
world and he's still recovering from
last week's show i won that nick mundy
thank you my voice is back and dan great
job that was a great intro you sounded
like a
professional radio man thank you that
was really good very genuine feelings
and there is actually i thought hal was
gonna have to step in so i mean this is
i know right oh well it's early in the
show nick uh i know one more thing also
on uh ironically the dan cam which i am
not able to be on this week we have uh
you know uh he does a show called uh red
shirt diaries on youtube and also he
works with us here at screen junkies
jason inman yes i will try to be my best
muralist
muralist yeah i like that yeah i like
that too we need a better dan cam like
intro like lightning bolts like like a
guitar riff we need intros for all i
want theme music oh yeah yeah uh so
jason
music now jason will be uh fact-checking
us throughout the show uh jason if we uh
make any big screw-ups just give us the
high sign you got it uh guys as always
we will be declaring a winner this week
so i will be keeping score as we go
based on passion creativity and just uh
overall uh quality of argument are you
impartial
of course i'm impartial how i'm a judge
do you get points for entrapping
at a comp opponent for saying something
stupid i don't know what entrapping
means but you know what it doesn't
matter because let's get on the road and
the immortal words of ken wadonabe
let them fight
there we go time for round one
so the big news the big news on twitter
what a lot of people wanted us to talk
about is we have all kinds of rumors
about dc suicide squad movie rumor's
been flying around we've got all these
casting rumors people are saying jared
leto's going to be the joker margot
robbie from wolf of wall street is
harley quinn uh oh our favorite jai
courtney is apparently being rumored as
deadshot we've got will smith in the mix
we've got tom hardy in the mix so that
brings us to our first question
what do you think of this rumored cast
of the suicide squad let's start with
how rudnick
i think the rumor cast is coming
together really nicely except for jai
courtney why are we giving him so many
chances he's um this year's taylor
kitsch i mean taylor kitch uh crapped
the bed so many times and he ran out of
chances jai courtney is only a chin he's
only a chin he's nothing else he's
worthless jared leto i think he'd be a
great joker it'd be a lot of fun weird
he can bring that weird energy margo
robbie i want to see a little more of
her you know what i'm talking about tom
hardy come on will smith could
potentially be good um if he if he lets
everyone play nice with him if he
doesn't try to dominate the thing um if
he doesn't uh and if if he definitely
keep jaden the f out of it
uh but uh yeah and your feud with jaden
continues oh debated jaden i'm calling
you out brother
um
uh hal vs jaden um but uh yeah lose jai
courtney the guy's like he
single-handedly ruined die hard and uh
die hard single-handedly ruined diehard
he was terrible
that that movie was just that's a whole
other fight all right so how you're
happy with the cast with the exception
of jai courtney yes let's head over to
mike carlson i am very happy with this
cast first of all i think it's cool what
they're doing they're going to put the
a-list villains in this movie it's not
gonna be the normal suicide squad which
is like c and d level which i think is
cool because you're just it's the heavy
hitters it's the it should be really
called the injustice gang or or
something like that the legion of doom i
would prefer but that's okay
jared leto is a joker jared leto was
terrifying he's gone if he if we all
learned oh jared leto just chopped up
somebody and put him in his basement we
go oh yeah i mean that makes sense like
i don't want to be in a room with him
he'd be a great joker margot robbie
great she's got charisma she's
attractive she's you know she seems to
be kind of universal people are in favor
of margot robbie that's the best casting
they may have done in the entire
dc student cinematic universe yeah i'm
not one for common consequences
i'm saying a nice thing to help him nick
is helping me out wow
uh point will smith as captain boomerang
amazing now who is captain boomerang
he's an australian character who throws
magi like not magic but like
technologically amazing boomerang he's
also a husky he's a husky fellow he's a
husky fellow he's a white guy in the
comics but
why would we not want to see will smith
throw a bunch of cool boomerangs around
although i wouldn't want to hear will
smith speak in an australian accent this
is where i disagree with you and i do
let's go over to nick bundy if will
smith is in an australian accent and he
puts on 50 pounds
this becomes my favorite movie but
until that happens here's my problem
here's my biggest problem with this
enough with the joker let's let's give
it a rest for a little bit there's so
many other villains in dc dc actually
has better villains than marvel let's
use some of them why not the riddler
let's do an obsessive compulsive like
you know like crazy smart
riddler like everyone needs the smart
funny guy on like some type of heist
team why not be the riddler it could be
joseph gordon or james franco given like
this insane like obsessive compulsive
funny performance i think that would be
great or like steve carell get him in
the uh fox catcher makeup have him be
the penguin
i mean let's let's just like i don't
care for jared leto he is scary as hell
so i agree with him but
let's just leave the joker
on the sidelines let's bring him when we
need him in a the spin-off batman movie
a couple years down the road let's focus
on these other characters because
deadshot's a great character i don't
want cj courtney play him but i want to
see matthew mcconaughey play
a dead shot i want to see him smoking
dead shots is laid back cool guy he's
got a mustache mcconaughey could
mcconaughey the hell out of him it would
be great and then if we do have to have
the joker i would prefer maybe like a
christophe waltz but like
let's put him to the sidelines and focus
on some other characters well that's a
good question uh before we wrap this up
uh is there like a dream character
dreamcast that you'd like to see in this
movie that we haven't heard about yet
mike uh well i said two weeks ago that i
want adam driver as the joker because i
want a weird another weird creep that i
could see chopping people up that i
would be uncomfortable with in a room uh
so i want that
uh i want brian krantz dennis lex luthor
that was a rumor a while ago why
wouldn't we want that one
it's like the same thing yeah
we do have a thing it's a you know
uh so i want those two guys i want to
say that sarcasm dc is playing catch up
here we need they need a big movie with
the biggest characters so like yeah it
would be nice to have the rhythm it
would be nice if we had a movie starring
the calendar man from batman that would
be great but they can't afford they
can't afford bookworm clock king louie
the lilac
but how do you leave joker on the
sidelines that's like doing justice
league and leaving batman on the
sidelines joker has such a great track
record nicholson did him well keith
ledger blew it out of the park that's
like you need joker to be like the
linchpin here's my bro here's my problem
don't do it you don't do you don't do
justice league without superman and
batman and uh you need the joker because
the suicide squad is anti-heroes and and
and like semi villains they're not just
the players joker is a great act i hear
how much
how much did we revel in watching heath
ledger yeah but you want cool
so you want anti-hero cool guy jared
leto joker like hanging out and like you
know maybe saving the day at one point
jared leto could um play like the just
unpredictable and kind of that vibe of
the joker that we have here's the thing
that we're about to see a movie although
a macaulay culkin joker would be really
i'm
yeah i would watch that all right guys
hold on real quick all right real quick
nick
they're also probably going to bring
jesse eisenberg's lex luthor into this
too so we're going to see a movie jury's
out jury's out on that yeah so we're
about to go all see a movie with jared
leto and jesse eisenberg as the two
leads i think we should just think about
that for
tom hardy's name's in there
will smith baby all right okay okay well
i mean you know let me listen it's who
knows if they're going to get all these
people um you all made great arguments
how i like the idea of macaulay hulking
is the joker uh mike i like your point
about the dc playing catch-up at this
point but i'm gonna give the point to
nick because i agree with your point
that suicide squad is kind of about
anti-heroes and the joker's a little too
too much of a villain so bringing the
heat goes to nick nice job coming out
strong let's go on to round round
two andy wouldn't let me have that one
well andy's not here is he
um that's it
you're right he probably won't have uh
all right so round two uh something else
we got a lot of tweets about uh we got
strangely enough we got some fantastic
four movie news which has kind of been
um kind of been a rarity these days uh
toby kebbel who's the new dr doom gave
an interview this week who revealed that
uh we kind of knew this that the
character's origins are going to change
according to him he will now be a quote
anti-social blogger
with the internet persona of doom who
then becomes dr doom uh you know to be
honest a lot of the movie that's come a
lot of the news has come out of this
movie has been a little controversial
with the fans we haven't seen anything
from it the release date's been pushed
it's a first-time director so this
round's question is
is there any hope for the new fantastic
four now before we get started uh we're
going to introduce a new feature on the
show called devil's advocate because to
be honest nobody on this panel or really
anybody we could find thinks there's any
hope for this movie but we need to we
need a good there might be a guy at fox
there might be a guy
but we need a good fight so uh nick
mundy
will be the devil's advocate on this
basically he will be making the argument
for now the advantage to nick making
this i'm a hero if he wins this argument
he gets two points that could be a
pretty that could be a pretty big lead
for you
we don't have devil horns or anything
but here's this copy of point break
starring keanu reeves who's also the
star of the movie devil's advocate quite
a stretch dan
i couldn't be bothered to find a copy of
the movie devil's actor there's probably
a better double reference somewhere in
here
uh you should have gotten a pacino movie
because he played the devil in that
movie well you know we would have could
have showed a house so uh let's start
with mike carlson new fantastic four
woody no chance there's no chance at all
for this because because we have we with
marvel we've been getting filet mignon
it's been like delicious steak and with
this fantastic four we're gonna get like
a knock off we're gonna get like
whatever the spam version of steak is
okay because you can just compare the
things like this is not gonna be like a
superhero movie they're not gonna have
the baxter building they're gonna be a
bunch of kids wearing hoodies and jeans
is that cooler than a bunch of people
wearing unstable molecules spandex suits
no it's not is dr doom is it cooler if
he's a ruler of latviria living in a
castle or is it cool if he's a weird
perez hilton style blogger and he's
drawing like a weird white liquid on
reed richard's face while he's making
these angry blog posts what is cooler i
vote for the latverian king there's just
no way there's no way we're going to
like this no it's a shitty thing is
someone at fox is watching right now and
there's like oh the president blogger
that's a good idea that's probably yeah
if somebody steals that idea from me
uh i'll be upset i don't know mike
carlson not hopeful nick let's hear your
devil's advocate argument all right
since i'm taking the hero's sword on
this one let's just we haven't seen
anything we've all we've heard was from
actors and actors we're all actors we're
dummies these people are dummies we
haven't seen anything we haven't seen a
trailer we haven't seen the
entertainment weekly terrible covers
like terminator let's see something
before we all jump to conclusions and
granted this all sounds terrible but
let's just wait
till we see something i mean the movie's
not even out i mean i know i'm a guy who
look i'm not a fan of the way fox does
the movies another way dc does a lot of
the movies but let's
let's not all be cliches let's just wait
and and start complaining until after we
see an image boy that's um shocking to
hear this yeah out of your mouth i know
please
that's
have to say that that was a very poor
job on devil's advocating because that
was
nick that was a non-answer what like you
were like let's remain neutral because
we've seen nothing um
like i wish you did a better job on the
devil's adventure
you did not give us anything positive so
nick is out this round um i let me let
me take what mike carlson said even that
much further oh boy um you
saw a huge blunder by the usually
infallible marvel with the mandarin they
totally pulled the rug out from under
the mandarin in iron man 3. wow ben
kingsley like you have such a great
actor to be this iconic villain and then
you make him a fake funny thing taking
dr doom one of the most fearsome
villains and making him like a some kind
of symbol on the internet created by a
blogger we already have kind of a
weasley bloggery type guy casting jesse
eisenberg as the potentially powerful
lex luthor like this is a class and you
could do that with lex luthor because
he's just a dude at the end of the day
dr doom is one of the most fearsome
awe-inspiring villains in the whole
universe and you're gonna neuter him
like this
no way bad move i thought this movie had
potential i was kind of in the nick
monday camp of like they're casting good
actors let's see if they can do it but
this ah this is like a death knell for
this movie to my
to my credit
that's the best i could come up with
the news is so bad but i've heard you
saying the praises of michael b jordan
before but and the rest of them he has
no idea what the movie is about like
yeah like you're oh and nick
you're just giving up yeah he's quitting
he's quick he's quick there's so much
more argument that you could have
brought on this
there isn't any argument
mike is there anything that excites you
about this movie well look i love
michael b jordan i think the cast is
good i think the filmmaker is pretty
good but when the when the cast is all
being like you know what this isn't
going to be a superhero movie it's like
guess what it's from guess what the
material is it's superhero so when
you're saying the actual thing that
makes this cool is not going to be in
the movie you're already going yeah by
the way don't see this let's not see
that here's the problem here's another
mandarin and the by the way the mandarin
might still be in the marvel universe
they dig there was a hint at the end of
a one shot so the mandarin that's what
it could have should have maybe um what
the future
okay but what they gave us currently is
nonsense here's the problem i gave the
same argument fox is giving because fox
has pushed the bat movie back if you
just officially given up on the devil's
okay
i want to shoot out the fantastic four
like where
where are the images where's the trailer
put something out no there was and it
was really disappointing at comic-con
that was the perfect opportunity for us
to give us a tasty morsel but nothing
comic-con was a barren wasteland can we
talk about that for a second
about this movie they would be fighting
this bad press there's too much bad
press found footage fantastic four movie
why why why that's what it is all right
guys that's worse that is what it's
going to be that's not good so i i had
someone to watch point i had two points
to give to nick mundy he sacrificed
those two points so you know what uh hal
and mike you both get a point
nick
you get nothing i i you know what i
don't want to be the guy who won on a
fantastic four point i don't want to be
okay and i've got uh i've got a our
jason what's up yes uh going off i have
a correction for the host oh going on
the found footage josh is not a first
time director he directed chronicles did
i say first time
that is my mistake i should have i
should have said
i should have said an unproven director
that's my bad that's embarrassing for
you oh that's so embarrassing i i'm
ruined uh all right let's go on to round
three
let them fight
uh another big piece of news this week
uh we found out that uh evil dead will
live on it's gonna be a ten episode
series on stars the big news starring
bruce campbell coming back as ash
produced by sam raimi so kind of a
second life for the evil dead so we
wondered
what other movie
should live on as a as a tv show as a
cable tv show let's start with nick
mundy okay um here's the thing well
first off we all agree that evil dead
coming back as a tv show is great like
having bruce campbell and sam raimi
attached right i'm on board okay so
all we get points yeah um
here's a movie here's a movie that i
thought was underrated that came out in
the mid 90s that features of someone
from the past coming to the future
to right wrongs from the past oh quantum
leap no they can't get the right to that
demolition man sylvester stallone's
demolition man an action-packed romp
where a man from the past takes on the
future solves his wife's crimes it could
be a great procedural on tnt i would
watch the [ __ ] out of that you get
wesley snipes in the cameo this would be
a great show plus you get dan cortez
some work again rob schneider somewhere
again we figure out what the three
seashells mean like this works out for
everyone this is a tv show i want to
watch so it'd be like a csi
but in the future yeah and you get
sylvester stallone
so sly would you start a tv show
so no recasting nope
all right
wow interesting wow uh
here's the thing um i have a dream show
i think it was a dream show uh how what
do you think um that is this podcast
called
rebuttal round yet
can we get some order to this show yes
how please please um
okay the best the best episodic series
that we could possibly uh have on cable
would be inception
every week we have a team going in to
get into the dreams of criminals
dictators uh bit like business tycoons
it would be amazing we have this crack
group and we can introduce new guest
stars who's who who who are we going to
get into and it could be some real
marquee cool casting this could be an
hbo show where we have like an awesome
guest star like every week whose brain
they go into and whose dreams they
discover oh man i would love to see this
group living in the shadows living on
the fringes hired by the government
hired by the highest bidder to go into
people's dreams it sounds kind of like
the a team
but inside people's dreams a-teams for
dreams call them the dream team but
don't call them the dream team because
it's inception do you want to sell the
dream team to cbs right now
um i'll do it okay so less moon viz on
the phone would it be the same cast or
would it be a different crew of dreams i
would love the same cast but i think it
would be a different crew because
dicaprio is not going to uh do it with
the demolition man we can get sly to do
the movie we can i don't know why
i don't want 70 year old demolition man
okay
get some
mike sorry i just like structure that's
what i'm talking about i can dock points
mike okay okay i'll be quiet uh that
being said mike
what's your show
all right this is going to be
controversial
i want an et television series
all right now hold a second hold on a
second there are some e.t things that
hint at the e.t verse what is involved
in it i'm talking about e.t the ride at
universal studios and a book sequel to
e.t called e.t the green planet now
we're probably talking alf meets fraggle
rock uh that's not a bad pitch for it
hell thank you for that so put a point
for me for that thing hell just said
what
okay e.t if you've been on the ride the
second half of the ride is e.t going
back to his home planet of broto asgoji
all right it is a lush green planet
filled with a bunch of et's and they're
all singing it's they're having a good
time and e.t has a best friend lush
green like pandora it's it is like
pandora only it's better the characters
are much more interesting on this planet
okay but it's still a ripoff of fern
gully
uh no i won't say it's a rip of a vern
yeah well it'll be a little bit like
fergal you're right about that so point
thank nick for helping me out on that
one uh e.t has a best friend named
botanicus who is like kind of half plant
half alien and in the book he helps e.t
create a spaceship and they grow it out
of a turnip and then e.t goes back to
earth i want the weirdest show possible
on cable it's what i'm trying to say
this stuff fine like okay we've seen
like human beings in a cable show i want
this on fx i want this on hbo i want to
really get into the facts yeah yeah yeah
all the networks like like a draw
anti-drug special 25 years ago so this
would be e.t the ride the show yes let's
call it that point for
me are both taking a dump on the
integrity of movie fights i at least
pick a movie not a ride because if we
wanted to spin off the ride i'll let's
do star tours you're not picking a movie
you're picking a damn taco bell
commercial my friend well i watched i
picked a movie
now nick nick do you just answer
demolition man to any question that's
asked of you and then hope that that's
an appropriate answer i want to come no
i've wanted this for years no no i
wanted i pitched this idea
on a job interview and they'll say and
um what's uh your greatest qualities
like demolition man
it's a great movie it's completely
underrated it's sylvester stallone's
probably third best movie what are his
first two rocky rambo demolition man
rambo is not better than rocky iii
is good hal's right about that is a
whole separate fight so why haven't we
talked about that fight we have
seven-year-old semester stallone and
demolition man tv show demolition man
the series on tnt is what nick just said
so think about that think about does
that like instill quality in your brains
no it does not demolition okay so that's
the man on tnt we've got
acceptabilities of going in different
dreams is just endless it will end up
being a cbs procedural so we have csi
and it will be here yeah csi inception i
mean look at i mean look at other movies
like look at fargo that became such a
great uh siri and that was a serious
movie it's like how could you do fargo
again and it's like they pulled it off
really well and then on mike's side
we've got uh e.t the insanely weird
sounding e.t and his best friend
botanicus
jason to help your uh decision dan yeah
i want you to know that everything mike
said is real 100 real yeah 100 right
that is not nonsense he was right on all
of it
botanicals don't we learn about
botanicals
or
calm down it's time for me to make my
decision uh mike that show sounds like
the craziest thing i've ever heard of in
my life tremendous nick i don't want to
see sylvester stallone uh on television
so how i'm giving you the point
inception thank you uh i think that
sounds like an interesting idea and i
liked your point about how they pulled
off fargo i thought that that was uh
that was an interesting point so thanks
brother you get the point on that round
let's go to round i'm going to make
demolition the tv i'm going to make a
movie about botanicus at least and i
won't watch either
oh yeah uh
this is actually uh one of our fans on
twitter asks chris on twitter uh asks
can m night shyamalan uh make a return
uh we got news this week that night
shyamalan's next film which he is also
writing and directing and producing is
called the visit uh universe is going to
release it in 2015. it's kind of a
return to form for him he'll be back in
control so the question is
can m night shyamalan make a comeback uh
how let's start with you three words
oh hell now
okay he has gone so far down the crapper
he has destroyed a beloved franchise
with the last airbender he has made
terrible movies lady in the water he has
made terrible movies that came back
around to be almost a funny hate watch
in the happening and he um oh and he
aligned himself with jaden smith you
mother f you dirty mother f okay yeah
why do you hate jaden smith so much oh
because um
like hollywood has chosen to give him
the mantle give him a crown and then
he's wondering and he's an idiot he's
done one movie he's done pursuit of
happiness and he's done the karate kid
and he's done um the uh the the movie
with his dad where they're quiet on a
planet for hours yes which was directed
by uh m night shyamalan
okay so
he he was great and then um he faltered
and then he faltered some more and then
he started grinding garbage into the
ground so no hope from hal redneck nope
mike carlson what do you think i'm going
to tell you a little story about a band
named aerosmith okay aerosmith was a big
hit in the 70s they went off the rails a
little bit with drugs and you know
personal problems and then they didn't
have really a big hit for a while they
decided to start writing songs with like
pro songwriters and they were back baby
dude looks like a lazy lazy
that's a parody
dude looks like a lady crazy crying
those those videos with they were back
they were the biggest hits m knight can
team up with another guy maybe write a
script somebody can right the ship okay
but you don't think he can do it on his
own i'm not saying that i'm just saying
there's a many possibilities for a man
to be able to turn it around because
aerosmith turned it around and m knight
can do it too so m91 according to mike
carlson could be the aerosmith of movie
directors that's right
let's go to nick
uh it's hard to argue against aerosmith
but here we go um
the problem is the question in of itself
a comeback would necessitate that he was
once great
that is not true he was okay he made one
and a half good movies and then a bunch
of crap what what are the one and a half
good ones the uh dead people the the
six cents
and half of unbreakable is pretty cool
like so not a science fan no okay that
was just claptrap okay um
you just saw everything happening that
was just claptrap
um he's not he he could sure i think he
could make a movie and be like hey the
guy from sixth sense made a decent movie
he's back to being decent again he was
never great he was never this visionary
everyone built him up to be i mean
he was on the cover of time magazine
he's an oscar-nominated director yeah to
be fair everyone everyone was billy's
who's great
but but like let's just put like you can
there have been freak show directors
that have made everyone did build him up
no they built him up like this great
director and i think and he never
capitalized on it because he was he was
okay like sixth sense is a pretty good
movie and then he hasn't done anything
since it's not like he has
yeah so how do you think he was at one
point a great director he was i
he had us believing he was he absolutely
uh he he snuck that was awesome the
twist was that he wasn't very good
that's what he was trying to say
it was all hype
no he had everyone on board he had
everyone fooled it wasn't hype it was
his magic but then it all became his
gimmick and then his megalomania
um ruined him
himself in every movie he made himself
the storyteller lady in the water is um
encapsulated he's a charlatan made
himself the the masterful storyteller
and then he pitted critics there's a
critic in the movie character critic
character and lady in the water who's
evil and bad and that was just sort of
like a little
microcosm of his career i am the
masterful storyteller critics are bad
and you bought it you bought you are not
lady in the water no but i but i never
saw him like i saw him for what he was a
decent director who science was good
unbreakable was really a cool super hero
yeah unbreakable is cool unbreakable is
called hell's right
and signs everybody was on board for
something like science so how i mean
there's really no refuting those
arguments you made but mike you're
saying that you know given all that he
can still he can still make of course
there was a time when he was making a
couple good move like like obviously
something somewhere some what lies
beneath uh m night i know he didn't
direct that movie i just thought it was
funny to say a movie like that uh what
lies beneath there's something in there
there's some creativity that is
obviously just not gelling right now and
obviously maybe you know what maybe he
needs some sort of a muse i'm not saying
he needs to have an affair with a lady
he just needs a person to inspire him to
make to come back to his three-star
movie career and then i'll come back and
say ah hell now because um we it was
like we were we've given him more
chances he's made bad movie after battle
the fact that we're having this
conversation is ridiculous because he
doesn't deserve the trickery that
everyone fell for yeah okay like that
you talked about i mean he's not this
great director he's never been this
great director okay he's proven with a
track record of crap now all right guys
i've got to make a call here um
you know i mean
everybody kind of i i agree with
everybody to a certain extent but uh you
know nick i disagree with you that that
he was never a great director i think
that he showed he has a lot of talent
and uh you know maybe i'm just an
optimistic person but i mike you won me
over with your point that maybe he just
needs the right inspiration i think the
raw talent's there so mike i'm gonna
give you the point
two movies make a great director
uh how many great movies have any of us
made exactly
let's move on to round five with my he
would have been convicted in any court
of law with my argument
uh round five uh okay no one would have
gone to court this is a weird question
but this is maybe my favorite question
that we got all week uh marissa putri on
twitter asked us
who is the best chris
pine hemsworth evans or pratt so guys
i'm gonna put that question to you
who's the best chris uh mike let's start
with you all right here we go
chris pratt and chris pine i like them
both they got they've got like a good
amount of charisma they're like decent
looking guys they're in nice shape like
they make great movie stars fine there's
about 10 other 20 other guys that are
like that okay chris pratt let's be
honest here
if any of us put on i said pine and
pratt oh did i screw up yeah okay i
screwed up can we we edited this out
right yeah
chris
chris no i'm just kidding hemsworth
crisp i know i'm going crisp chris pine
and chris evans is who i'm talking about
gotcha chris pratt okay if any of us put
on 50 50 pounds of muscle or something
we could be chris pratt i could be chris
pratt not a big deal okay
chris hemsworth is who i'm talking about
he is a literal god look at him watch
that first thor movie okay natalie
portman
falls in love with him before our eyes
we can tell exactly why he doesn't seem
of this world i remember right after
that movie came out i was standing in
line for another movie and there were
these middle-aged ladies who were just
talking about thor and they weren't
saying his name they just thought he was
thor and i think that's something we all
believe in he is a literal god is what
i'm saying they wanted thor to tame some
cougars huh so
chris hemsworth you're saying because he
is uh he he is his character he's larger
than life yes all right nick best chris
look i'll wash a car with any of these
guys
like they're all they're all tasty
dishes oh yeah shirtless charity car
wash oh yeah they are they're and
they're also jean shorts and they're
also dudes that would go to dinner with
and have a good time and stare into
their eyes yeah but uh sometimes this
guy likes to drink a beer
and of all these guys the only one who's
gonna drink gluten is pratt
and uh so i just want to hang out drink
a beer i kind of draw right now uh and
hang out with pratt play some guitar and
just just talk about the world so you're
saying the other guys are a little too
fancy pants to drink
yes yeah i doubt in their
yeah i don't think they drink miller
light with me so that's the only one
that's gonna happen i want someone to
drink 12 beers with me on an afternoon
while fishing whoa and it's going to be
chris pratt and okay those other and
we'll probably talk about those guys how
they're great guys and they're nice to
look at but uh i want to hang out with
pratt all right nick wants to have a
several beers with chris pratt he wants
to binge drink with chris pratt uh how
who's your who's your choice okay well
um i'm also picking chris pratt but uh
i'm going to pick it for pick him for
reasons that neither of you have talked
about like
mike is is talking about um
the is picking um at the end of the day
the most handsome one okay well they're
all they're all handsome they're all
handsome
yeah you pick basically the most
god-like looking one the most handsome
dude you pick um nothing and you didn't
talk about acting ability or their
performance because i don't want to
bother everything i just want to hang
out i don't want to pressure him right
but i just want to be a friend i don't
care like you guys are nice guys i have
enough nice dudes to hang out with in my
life i want to talk about the guy i want
to see like helm uh like like take the
reins of a major character and watch
okay i feel like hemsworth and evans
cancel each other out captain america oh
he's an awesome just embodiment of the
american boy next door just superhero um
thor
he uh hemsworth did an awesome job uh
pine i don't like that guy
really yeah what did personally or
didn't he really run over your dog just
seems kind of smart he's a good dude i
don't know
trying seems kind of smarmy and i know
like he you know i i just he was hitting
on this girl that i liked it wasn't the
captain oh that's what it was the
captain yeah the captain kirk yeah the
whole the whole thing i just am not a
fan okay pratt pratt uh he is like the
younger robert downey jr with that
performance uh from guardians of the
galaxy he not only was handsome
not only a good actor as we've seen in
various films zero dark 30 and what have
you but he's got the he is funny he is
legitimately funny and brought a wry
sense of humor that hemsworth could not
do um so so uh mike you're the own
you're the only one that did not go with
chris pratt that's correct
i went with chris hemsworth i mean
here's the deal again you said we know a
bunch of funny guys you want to have a b
i can have a beer with anybody okay i
you know what i'd rather have mead with
hemsworth all right i'd rather go chug a
whole thing of mead in asgard with this
guy he is not like any person i know
like who who's uh the better um movie
star with more potential or who would
you want to hang out with i think it
just says who's the best yeah and i want
to hang out with the dude who would
probably come on the show and he would
probably come on the show with me and
because we're drunk
and he's going to have a good time i
aspire to something greater than just
hanging out i want to join the gods in
celebration that is what i'm trying to
say all right well so guys i got to make
a call here uh
it sounds to me like nick and i'm sorry
hal and mike you just want to hang out
with these guys and ask them marvel
questions uh i'm gonna give the point to
nick cause it sounds like he really
actually likes the dude and he wants to
hang out with him it's not always about
work so nick gets the point and guys uh
i was speaking metaphorically also i
didn't really look i wasn't talking
about hanging out at all i was talking
about who we'd want to see in him you
wouldn't want to hang out with me i know
that just kind of like you would ask
them guardians questions you know what
though here's the thing we all win
because these chris's are good folk all
right guys let's move on like we have an
embarrassment of riches when it comes to
christmas all right all right guys let's
move on to round six thank you melissa
it's chris miss by the way uh yes by the
way no pressure but after five rounds uh
everyone is tied um so just you know put
that in the back of your head uh so
round six um
let's talk about quentin tarantino we've
actually gotten a lot of requests uh
since we've been doing the show to talk
about tarantino uh he was at an american
film market event this week uh for the
hateful eight uh and he said that he
plans to make two more movies and then
uh hang it hang it up and retire
completely like now
whether you believe that or not which is
another debate uh it seemed like a good
time to ask what is the best quentin
tarantino movie nick let's start with
you okay uh i will fully admit i like
quentin tarantino he's good i'm not like
in love with him but i get why people
love his movies
uh so you're not a fan no i am a fan
okay i'm just like said he's fine he's
fine i'm i'm a super fan although i i'm
a big kill bill fan and i was lucky
enough three years ago to see the kill
bill the whole bloody affair
at the new beverly
and it was awesome and it makes me
disappointed why they cut the movie to
and i knew you would see this um
and it just it makes me mad that they
split together because it's just a
better cut it the story flows and it i
feel like it's his best movie and also
i might not be a great tarantino fan but
i was a fan enough to go see the movie
and it might not ever show up again and
it's a rarity
and i win
all right nick making the call for us um
not really though how what do you think
i couldn't go see that movie because i
was doing volunteer work
at an orphanage i don't recall uh-huh
i did young storytellers around the same
time and i did it that day and then okay
all right i was in the big brother
program one i really wasn't i know uh
okay um
so
it hands down i mean i love kill bill
and i imagine that was great but hands
down it's a pulp fiction pulp fiction
was a game changer i mean pick your
favorite scene from pulp fiction uh do
you have like an hour for me to sit back
and think okay well the best scene no um
the casting that you know that thing
that happens sometimes where um
like they pick a cool actor to
revitalize his career um tarantino does
it now a lot of other directors do it um
it started in pulp fiction okay you know
how like sometimes like you have awesome
soundtracks and like wes anderson films
and like quentin tarantino films and
other cool uh it started in pulp fiction
so you're saying that pulp fiction was a
game changer that that set trends that
we are still seeing um indeed and uh it
was such an awesome film when it comes
to time construction and redefining cool
there are so many things that pulp
fiction did that sent shock waves
through american pop culture and movie
making that it and it stands aloft as
the crown jewel of a great career
quentin tarantino all right
revitalize john travolta's career
might not be the best thing in the world
but he was talking about it in that
movie mike carlson what's your fault all
right these are both
movies that i love a lot but the movie
that i love the best that is the best is
jackie brown okay jackie brown is just
cool it's the coolest of his movies it's
something that i can put on anytime and
watch let's talk about the performances
robert forster amazing just the
understated play like it's just so great
the love story between him and jackie
brown it's not even they barely kiss at
the end a little bit and that's all it
needs that's all it needs it doesn't
need some crazy arc it doesn't need
anything sam jackson robert de niro
robert de niro says i think 20 words in
this movie and he's amazing uh this is
just something that i can put on any
time and watch again i love pulp fiction
but pulp fiction is like something i
like i really have to like kind of watch
and pay attention to jackie brown
anytime catch it in the middle it's
amazing so it's your favorite but do you
think it's his best movie
uh yes because that's what we were
arguing about okay um that's a little
bit silly that you can't put on pulp man
pulp fiction there's so many jewels in
that movie just put it on any time and
just oh drink it
nick what do you think what do you think
of pulp fiction and jackie brown
uh
pulp fiction's great i actually i love
jackie brown that's probably my second
favorite gwen tarantino movie okay
jane
um
but again
i am a big action guy
uh so my
yeah choices tend to go to kill bill
and that cut i hope it comes out but if
it doesn't i feel better about myself
because i took the time to see it i
didn't make it as powerful an argument
for django as i could for kill bill as i
could firing glorious bastards each one
is of merit pulp fiction uh is on
a mount rushmore of american film so i
mean you know here's the thing with
tarantino is we're all gonna be dicks if
we start [ __ ] on all of these movies
yeah you can pick any of this but this
is movie fights yeah okay so okay i mean
if you if you watch it
i don't think like that soundtrack thing
if you want if you want movie hugs why
don't you go call the teletubbies and
start your own damn podcast monday all
right uh so no here's the thing
eddie
nick are you okay over there yeah
is it building yeah okay all right i'm
waiting for the soundtrack question
catch it uh yeah i mean here's the thing
any of tarantino's movies you can
probably pick and uh except for death
proof uh and make a good argument a good
argument about uh
i'm gonna give a little nod here to andy
at the end of the day
uh i like mike i like that you took the
underdog choice and i think you fought
passionately for it kill bill and pulp
fiction both great movies but mike you i
liked your argument so i'm going to give
the point to mike thank you if you were
such a big queen tarantino fans wouldn't
have seen the kill bill
the whole bloody affair are you calling
out their fandom now yes not everybody
can be everywhere
it was playing for a while it wasn't
just one night was it was two weeks yeah
two weeks good time there was one month
i saw it mike saw it okay yeah we're
going to talk about who's the biggest uh
tarantino fan by the way
than you worship's about rushmore i
would think i mean pulp fiction like the
fact that guys guys
lost the round is over we're moving on
to round seven you're a child
yeah
oh boy things are getting heated in here
uh round seven uh last week we talked
about interstellar uh it actually was
beaten at the box office last week by
another movie uh big hero 6 which is
getting great reviews um i liked it and
people are loving it uh mainly a lot
mainly due to baymax which is this robot
who teams up with the kid to kind of
form a superhero team uh he's a great
like sidekick so we thought we would ask
who's the best sidekick
of all time
nick let's start with you a sidekick
should support the hero
make the hero laugh question the hero
and ultimately
at the end of the day when everyone
thinks that the bad guys are killed and
then the bad guy shows up pulls out his
machine gun and points at john mclean
shoots him in the brain
sergeant al powell played by reginald
johnson
is the greatest sidekick of all time
these two formed a friendship without
ever meeting each other
how powerful is that they had the use of
radio
and
they became
true friends and partners and at the end
of the day he saved the day at the end
of the day you can almost make the
argument al pal is the hero of die hard
because he saved john mclean interesting
he's just a man who has a pregnant wife
who might have diabetes
and
he does like twinkies yeah but he didn't
run he stood up against agent johnson
and special agent johnson
against the the whole lapd the principal
for uh breakfast yeah and he
stood by his man the entire time without
even meeting him
all right al pao that's a pretty that's
a stirring argument for uh reginald
johnson there how what do you think
stood by his man because he had nothing
better to do he was just getting he had
a pregnant wife to ignore yeah and like
he was just getting uh some snacks and
uh what would you have done what would i
have done i don't know he he was decent
um die hard great movie great villain
but the greatest sidekick of all time
why wouldn't the greatest movie have the
greatest sidekick
because it didn't and the greatest uh
sidekick was in wayne's world
garth algar
is by far the greatest sidekick of all
time um talk about supporting the hero
talk about um being there having his
back and talk about being able to steal
a scene every once in a while oh man not
just stealing a scene stealing the movie
dana carvey beats mike meyer so you're
saying that garth is the real star of
wayne's world garth is then why would
you call him the sidekick that's what i
would say why would you call it would
you call cogs the sidekick to murdoch
well but no but i mean in the movie he
set up
me as always fellas easy answer what's
the name of the movie wayne's world okay
garth algar is the second banana on the
fictional tv show that took place in
aurora illinois and he's the sidekick he
in the movie and he dominates he brings
mad heat he brings stupid game with kim
bassinger okay he's funny as hell i
guess i just respect garth enough to put
them at level playing that's right i
would agree with nick it's called
wayne's world so mike and nick you say
he that he's he's an equal playing yeah
if he's better like we want a sidekick
needs to complement the hero he doesn't
need to be equal they're a duo that's a
different thing
all right hal you've had your chance let
mike talk now my sidekick pick is a new
movie by the way i'm your sidekick
that's like okay that i'm a great
sidekick to you
you know all right well thank you guys
all right i want to talk now your edge
and mike out here come on root groot is
the best sidekick wow okay it's a new
pick but let's think about this he's
rocket sidekick rocket is obviously the
talker he has the most to say he is he
plans groot is an amazing compliment he
has all the things you need to be a good
sidekick catchphrase
we've been saying it since the movie
came out i'm groot i say it five times a
day okay i say it at the drive-through i
say it at the grocery store i go i'm
groot or whatever that's that's the
thing that i do i'm assuming everyone
else does it hodor
awesome fighter he's amazing that time
when he just shoved his tree limbs right
through like five guys and slammed him
that's amazing and then
in that same place cute he turned around
he has that smile he's cute a sidekick
needs to be cute because the main guy
needs to be the hard ass okay
heroic in the first movie he sacrifices
himself he doesn't even know he's gonna
come back at the end he says i care so
much about this team i am willing to die
for them that's what you need in a
sidekick
you just undercut your own argument
against me i don't see how um because
you said a sidekick needs to be cute
garth is the cute one wayne is the alpha
male okay sorry all right i'm sorry
you're saying original johnson's not
sexy mundy what what are you what are
your thoughts on group well i think you
should be disqualified because i thought
we weren't bringing up marvel
oh that was not that was not part of
this well i just i just think it's bad
you made that rule up now i know i did i
just think it's banner but what do you
think of groot he's fine but he's part
of a team he's not a sidekick anymore
he's part of a team well that's
incorrect he's a sidekick to a rocket no
they're all equal
guardians of the galaxy not guardians of
the galaxy featuring groot they're all
they're all level playing when they go
and have their solo adventures though
they are together they don't have it by
themselves in the realm i feel like
talking about groot isn't even a better
sidekick than chewbacca
oh groot's way better than chewbacca no
that's a fight that's a fight though we
should let's have that yeah
mike what do you think about al pal from
die hard look it's great but like
they're not even they they don't they're
not on screen together like it's cool
and like how powerful it is and did
there did that friendship or
sidekickness go on did it go on die hard
too he faxed them information but did it
go on to die hard four
no well no because it was ruined
because obviously they're not that good
of friends or that good of partners or
cycle obviously agreed with that um
getting back to garth not being wayne's
side okay that's i think i mean you've
made your argument for garth i think i
mean yeah it's been well argued and i
can't poke holes in what uh they're
saying all right you have 20 seconds
that's like saying in the old 60s tv
show batman and robin that just because
he's a titular character that um robin
is not batman's sidekick where he
clearly is
i'm not sure that i'm following you
there how
they said because they're a duo uh wayne
and garth are like a package deal batman
and robin were a package deal but robin
was clearly the sidekick but one okay
all right all right well you know what
guys i'm gonna make a call on this um
i like the argument that you guys made
that wayne is kind of that garth is kind
of wayne's equal even though it is
called wayne's world uh mike i you know
i i like groot i think he's cool but but
nick you had a really good argument for
al pal and die hard he did compliment
the hero and even though they never met
on screen i thought that uh that you
know i i think i like your i like your i
like your argument so nick you get the
point on that round let's run
like i'm not gonna lose on a die hard
final round round eight
uh so this is a bit of a tease for uh
this week's honest trailer um last week
we kind of blew it but we didn't blow it
but we had a disney movie last week we
have another disney movie coming up this
week so
uh what we will tease is that it is
disney it is animated and it has awesome
songs in it which i think should kind of
narrow it down
but since it has great music in it we
decided to ask
what movie has the best soundtrack of
all time disney movies there's a lot of
great soundtracks in disney movies and
just movies in general so which one is
the best how let's start with you
there absolutely are a lot of great ones
but the greatest soundtrack of all time
uh
culmination putting together songs for a
movie is trainspotting there is no
better album there is no
better compilation of songs that were
part of a movie than trainspotting i
mean
try to beat
any of you try to beat
perfect day by lou reed and lust for
life by iggy pop
that's it's impossible and uh as two
great songs lust for life man what a
barn burner that song is and lou reads
perfect day if you just want the most
beautiful song uh there you have it so
so train's fighting on the strength of
two songs on this oh no uh you have uh
way more than that uh
you have
a new order on there you have so much
great brit pop and new wave on that
soundtrack um and punk
oh my god all right those are the those
are the two lead dogs those two songs
what do you think greatest soundtrack
those are good songs greatest soundtrack
though i can beat that when it's a movie
starring and soundtracked by the beatles
hard day's night ladies and gentlemen
okay this is the biggest band of all
time anybody that's going to talk about
songs would not have made songs if it
weren't for the beatles all right hard
day's night it's a hard day's night i
should have known better i want to be
your man all my loving if i fell these
are classic songs
nobody can beat these songs it's the
beatles they're in the movie this this
whole how many times have we seen this
movie parodied for god's sake i mean
this is the most influential thing ever
all right nick i picked a soundtrack
that's not only the best soundtrack for
a movie
but a gender not and not only a
generation but a country
so you're picking a soundtrack for
america dazed and confused oh okay you
got rock and roll hoochie coo slow right
school's out jim dandy love her
strangled fox on the run low rider
tuesday's gone rock and roll night
paranoid you got kiss you got black
sabbath you got ted nugent you got the
runaways you got
zz top i just realized ted nugent's not
a real bona fide but back then he was
okay rick derringer it is a defensive
nugent can go f himself i just ruined
your argument
yeah it doesn't hurt but you're saying
it's it's that is america's soundtrack
classic rock and roll america rock and
roll and it's the best soundtrack ever
made it's the best compilation ever made
for music how uh what do you think of uh
you want america rock and roll how about
almost famous how about guardians of the
galaxy there are like so many great
except this is better okay oh all right
like it's been done time and time again
ad nauseum uh
i mean lust for life and perfect day
those two songs and then you have uh
temptation by new order and there's so
many great other songs on that
soundtrack so great that it spawned a
second soundtrack that uh including
david bowie like it was so good that it
gave birth to another um better than
that soundtrack and the beatles that's a
music film okay let me uh should i pick
rattle and hum or should i pick yeah i'm
gonna pick jesus christ superstar yeah
right why couldn't you pick that no
because uh it's like okay let me pick a
concert film how about um rolling stone
not a concert phone i'll just pick up a
revolver okay like you know mike what do
you say what do you think about their
character well first of all i'm going to
say that her hard day's night has a
narrative it is about something it is
not just rattle and hum it is not just
uh you know what it was the other one
somebody said i don't even care but i'm
just saying it's a narrative there's a
whole thing somebody gets lost they're
running away from the from young chicks
in britain that's a movie folks yeah now
here's my question to both of you henry
leonard skinner's songs are on your
soundtrack
none thank you one thank you folks
leonard skinner these are all all of
these songs yeah they're good but like
this is what you're gonna hear at like
the o'shea's casino cover band in vegas
okay these are songs i like when i die
and when i get married these are the
songs that we'll be playing this isn't
confusing
the tuesday's gone is the best song ever
made okay do you okay like well that's
you guys don't love two days ago it's
scary it's good it's a good song
listen i'm not saying that album uh it
doesn't rock but this rocks harders and
blows mine and it has more levels what
what song on that uh that you just named
has the level of uh perfect day rock and
roll all night
bs
all right yes and none of these would be
exist if it weren't for the beatles all
i'm saying you know not true everybody's
made compelling arguments uh you know
it's tough uh how i you didn't seem that
familiar with your choice
so that counts a little bit against you
uh nick i hear you on uh i hear you on
what you're saying it is a great
compilation you're from arkansas you're
from arkansas i am from arkansas that's
right and i agree that's great music to
be honest i almost want to not give
anyone a point because nobody said
purple rain which i think would have
been a slam dunk in this contest but
it's a good soundtrack i am gonna give
the point to mike because i agree it's
original music it is a soundtrack it is
a movie
uh
and it's iconic music i mean you don't
get much better than the beatles if
someone said purple rain that would have
been a fight so mike gets the point and
with that mike gets the win mike oh
two-and-oh
here on movie fights nick uh how you
guys were close behind jason how were
were we clean today you're fine we're
good all right mostly accurate we cut
jason completely out of the show so
congratulations to mike carlson two
times thank you for having me champion
hell have you won i have not
nick still winless so guys uh what did
you think was these fights nick i'm
trying to do my plugs here come on i
know i'm just uh
how did i do by the way did i do okay no
you did much better than you thought i
thought you were fine i mean i i thought
like you know your choices were
obviously poor i thought the judging was
really good i don't know why no judging
terrible but timber in the voice and
performance yeah that's as far as
keeping the show moving that's good yeah
i worked on my timber uh guys what did
you think of these fights if you're
watching on youtube please tell us in
the comments below tell us what you
thought and more importantly tell us
what you want to see us fight about next
week also since a lot of you are
watching on youtube i just want to
remind you please we are on itunes as
well so can go and look for us there uh
we'll have audio versions of this show
uh each week at the link in the
description uh and also please show us
your love by rating subscribing
commenting on itunes and if you're
listening to us on itunes please check
us out on our youtube channel screen
junkies youtube.com screenjunkies for a
lot of awesome shows i want to thank our
panelists
hal rudnick yes please uh follow me on
twitter at hal rudnick uh yeah we'll
we'll shoot the crap and uh talk about
what you had for lunch today the
returning champion mike carlson thank
you uh you can reach me at twitter at
fat carlson p-h-a-t-c-a-r-l-s-o-n
hashtag botanicus i want to get botanic
as trending please hashtag botanicus uh
nick mundy i'm uh dick fundy and while
you're at itunes you might as well buy
some skinner because it's the best music
ever made all right uh and again we want
to thank our amazing friends here at the
popcorn talk network maria menounos uh
kevin undergirl fellow howard stern fans
hey now uh
the the schmoes know christian harloff
and mark ellis and if you love this show
if you love movie fights the popcorn
talk network's youtube channel has tons
of awesome movie related shows you got
meet the movie press you've got marvel
movie news jedi alliance and that'll be
a movie so many cool shows uh you can
check that out at their youtube channel
youtube.com
popcorntalk network hey guys ask me if
mike deserved to win today did mike
deserve to win today oh hell no all
right hashtag botanicus hey let's also
you got in all snooty about it last week
you forgot to thank jason oh you're
right how could i do it jason and the
day you're right i'm a i'm a serial
official
red shirt diaries guys thank you so much
this is a great movie fights hashtag
botanicus how why don't you take us out
of here thanks for watching bye bye
every podcast we put on youtube comes
with this kick-ass graphic listing all
the topics your favorite screen junkies
podcasters are talking about if you
click the topics you can skip around and
choose your own podcast battle royale go
ahead try them all
if you haven't already subscribe to
screen junkies on youtube to join us for
future fights or if you prefer to listen
on itunes click the logo to download an
audio version lastly please support our
friends at the popcorn talk network for
more awesome shows